distintas organizaciones internacionales
registran que la inmigración de
venezolanos aumentó drásticamente tras
la muerte de Chávez y la toma de
posesión de Nicolás maduro por qué
Pues bueno Buenas tardes Esto se debe
entre otras cosas a factores económicos
y factores económicos que No
necesariamente
están relacionados con el ascenso al
poder de Nicolás maduro sino que tienen
también mucho que ver con la propia
política económica de Hugo Chávez y muy
particularmente con la política
petrolera la industria petrolera
venezolana fue fuertemente politizado
Durante los años de Chávez con en un
intento por controlarla por mantenerla
alineada con los intereses de la
Revolución bolivariana y esto afectó por
supuesto las capacidades técnicas de la
industria cuando muere Chávez y al año
siguiente hay un proceso de caída
drástica en los precios de la del
petróleo en el mundo pues la industria
petrolera fundamentalmente la empresa
pedevesa no se puede recuperar y maduro
termine heredando entonces una crisis
económica que trata de compensar con
autoritarismo esa combinación entre
pérdida de capacidades económicas de un
estado Que prácticamente lo subsidiaba
todo junto con el autoritarismo y la
represión pues alentaron la de
inmigración y ahora pasemos a la
situación de los emigrantes venezolanos
en América Latina muchos son objetivo de
un racismo generalizado le pregunto si
esto tiene que ver con las clases las
clases sociales que emigran de una forma
o de otra
sí fundamentalmente En el caso de la
xenofobia que se ha generado en torno a
muchos venezolanos en América Latina
pues tiene que ver también con el origen
socioeconómico de esos venezolanos tiene
que ver adicionalmente con la
penetración de esos flujos migratorios
por parte de bandas criminales y dado
que América Latina es el espacio natural
de la expansión migratoria sobre todo
venezolanos que no tienen recursos para
migrar al norte global por ejemplo
Entonces es allí donde estamos viendo
mayores casos de xenofobia de rechazo y
por supuesto de políticas
discriminatorias sobre todo en países
andinos con la excepción de Colombia
pero pero políticas discriminatorias muy
importantes que tienen que ver
precisamente con esa aporofobia que se
suma por supuesto a la xenofobia que es
esa fobia a la Pobreza exacto y pasando
al futuro de Venezuela por ejemplo
Colombia ha retomado relaciones con
Caracas la toma de posesión de Gustavo
Petro Estados Unidos ha permitido a
Chevron que vuelva a operar en Venezuela
por ejemplo a condiciones así de que
avancen los diálogos entre oficialismo y
oposición en Venezuela ve posibilidades
de un regreso digamos más amplio de
Caracas al tablero internacional y de
una mejora por lo tanto económica en el
país
pues ya está regresando Venezuela a ese
tablero internacional y particularmente
el tablero de occidente y de América
Latina fundamentalmente de la mano de
Colombia pero también de otros países
como México por ejemplo
Argentina Brasil en el caso de chile no
es así el presidente boric tiene una
distancia muy marcada y unas objeciones
muy fuertes en contra del gobierno
Nicolás Maduro pero si hay una
reapertura y una reinserción de
Venezuela en el marco de la política
latinoamericana y occidental y esto pues
se refleja en estas estos permisos que
se le dan a empresas petroleras como
Chevron la estadounidense para que siga
operando a cambio por supuesto de alguna
flexibilización política no creo
necesariamente que esto vaya a llevar a
un proceso al menos no en el corto
mediano plazo a un proceso de apertura
política pero sí quizás de cierta
flexibilización de las condiciones sobre
todo para los llamados presos políticos
para la la para la operación mucho más
libre de la oposición pero ya estamos
viendo en paralelo que se están
desarrollando normativas que van a
regular y van a limitar la actividad de
las organizaciones no gubernamentales
extranjeras en el país Entonces estamos
viendo en realidad una reinserción sin
necesariamente una democratización pero
adicionalmente estamos viendo una
economía que es muy frágil todavía una
economía que sigue siendo muy
dependiente del petróleo pero con una
industria petrolera que no tiene la
capacidad del pasado y entonces Esto
hace que la sociedad y la economía
venezolana está en una situación de
constante crisis de la cual no terminan
de salir y para cerrar Víctor tal y como
empezamos con esta década de la muerte
de Hugo Chávez le pregunto cómo entender
que pese a la crisis que atraviesa el
país que usted ha atribuido entre otras
cosas la estructura política creada por
Chávez él siga siendo el político más
valorado de Venezuela
Pues yo creo que esto tiene que ver con
factores digamos de carisma propio de
Hugo Chávez de la relación que que
mantuvo con una parte importante de la
población venezolana Pero adicionalmente
hay unos factores estructurales que
tienen que ver con altos precios del
petróleo y una industria petrolera que
todavía tiene una capacidad para
producir incluso más de tres millones de
barriles diarios exportar más de dos
millones de barriles diarios con eso no
cuenta Nicolás Maduro ni con factor
carismático ni con el factor económico
de allí que se mire ahora desde
Venezuela al chavismo prácticamente como
una era dorada no y que Hugo Chávez
cuando se le compare se le vea Entonces
como un líder de mayor calado que
Nicolás Maduro o cualquier líder de la
oposición